on our calendar joey versus
williams bradley pitt
angie's attorney pushed hard this
morning for more than 30 minutes in a
remote appellate court hearing
he argued that the private judge in
their custody battle case was not
impartial
because he was working on legal matters
involving brad's lawyers
she was shocked to find out that it
hadn't been disclosed to her
it makes the appearance of things not
being on the up and up
all that stronger brad's attorney fired
back that jolie knew about the potential
conflict
all along here in a child custody case
that's been going on so long the
children are getting older and to allow
a delaying tactic like this would be
extremely unjust
family law attorney kelly chang rickard
who watched the hearing
says angie may be fighting a losing
battle i mean she really
is reaching here i would think they
would have a decision
within the next day or so i went to my
account
so how did it get so messy for the exes
and former co-stars
i wanna know what this is do you wanna
hurt me angie filed for divorce in 2016.
pitt was under investigation for alleged
child abuse after a family incident
aboard a private jet
brad denied the allegations and was
later cleared of any wrongdoing
but that incident on the jet may have
been a turning point for brad and led
him to get sober
this is for my kids who color everything
i do i adore you
in may brad won a major victory
temporary joint custody of their five
minor children
if she loses this appeal there's one
more shot she could petition to the
supreme court of california
you